I'm Diablo Cody the writer of Jennifer's
Body I'm beggin Fox and I play Jennifer
check-in Jennifer's Body we're just here
to talk about the film ten years after
its release why don't you just come by
my place was random
this isn't really your house is it
something that people actually do ask me
about a lot and I don't ever have the
answers for is like the inception of
this project so I have a specific
question of my own but just in general
for you how did it start and how did I
get involved in this movie and Amanda
and everyone else well okay so I
specifically my entire life had dreamed
of writing a horror movie
I'm a huge horror fan and it's I had you
know at the time that I wrote Jennifer's
body I had only done one feature at that
point I had written Juno which is not a
horror movie
unless you think unwanted pregnancy is a
horror which I guess it kind of is yes
for me it was just the fulfillment of a
dream and Juno had been a successful
movie so coming off of that I was sort
of given carte blanche to write anything
that I wanted and it's very rare for a
screenwriter to have that kind of
creative freedom and indeed I have not
enjoyed that level of creative freedom
since so I just thought alright this is
it like I'm gonna write my crazy gonzo
horror movie and I want it to be female
focused I want it to be about a female
friendship and I specifically want it to
be about a girl who eats boys I wanted
to be about like cannibal isn't about
sex and empowerment revenge and all that
stuff and I just I knew what I wanted
and so I wrote the script and that was
if I recall correctly a very
free-flowing and exciting and easy
process and I think I was aware of how
bizarre it was like right off the bat I
was like this is not a super commercial
movie but I was lucky enough to get
Karan Kusama attached to direct and then
it the big question became who's going
to play Jennifer and honestly everybody
else like for instance the character
needy like we read a lot of people and
we talked to a lot of actresses I
remember sitting down with like I'm a
snow
like but before we realized that amanda
seyfried was clearly perfect for the
part but jennifer we always knew that
was you there was no question about it
I'm sure you remember being approached
like early on in the process yeah what
was it about me and it made you think
that I could play a psychopath that
devours boys she knew what it was I
think and this is a compliment okay
you have mystique which not a lot of
particularly now in this era of social
media and people being completely
accessible it's it's rare and old movie
stars had mystique it was it was hard to
imagine for instance you know what I'm
not going to name names
I will just say many of the actresses in
your cohort I could not imagine playing
Jennifer because they did not have this
sort of self-possessed Ava Gardner type
quality that you have
and we just we just knew we had seen
transformers you're laughing that her
favorite subject oh I don't mind - I
actually don't mind talking about it
anymore I've come full circle was I was
tough yeah I'm I've been on a total
journey with that and I've made it back
to a place where nothing that I've
experienced is a bad thing it was always
something that grew me in the right
direction to where I am now so I'm not I
don't I don't hate do hate talking about
something because it's people associate
it with you so much they're like I'm
tired of talking about it or because you
had a bad experience well I have to say
there was an era we were an era I'd make
it sound like it was a hundred years
there was a time when it was painful for
me to talk about Jennifer's body because
you know that movie was a commercial
failure yeah and like I was savaged
personally it wasn't just having a
professional failure and so it was hard
and I had written about it a lot and I
had talked about
I mean I've actually gone through
therapy because of that experience and
now 10 years later I genuinely love
talking about it I'm happy I'm so happy
to be here talking with you about it I
but I I think part of that is because
we're being validated now yeah people
people suddenly the movie has suddenly
found its audience yeah are you PMS
or something PMS isn't real Navy it was
invented by the boy run media to make us
seem crazy did you feel like you're
being savaged by critics personally or
you felt like other people in the
industry we're coming after you or where
did you feel the attack was coming for
you I mean during that process I felt
like people in the industry definitely
were coming for me if you recall the
movie came out in like the early days of
Twitter and I don't i've never week
you're not like a social media person
kind of vaguely maybe people are very
careful with their tweets these days but
back then it was a new twitter was a new
social media platform and people were
like reckless so I would like search my
name which is idiotic I don't do that do
that I do not do that stuff anymore and
I would see like actual peers of mine
like other writers and other directors
making fun of me and making fun of the
movie I guess assuming I wouldn't see
the tweet but it was like oh my god like
I'm being attacked from the inside like
I am you know and critics were awful
wait sit for me what was surprising was
I felt like they didn't actually watch
the movie like how could they review it
the way that they did after having
watched the movie I do feel like
obviously it was miss marketed and I
think that's probably you probably feel
a lot of anger about that right or you
did at the time because it was no way
yeah that that it didn't really give it
much of a chance but it's their job to
be impartial and be neutral and to watch
a movie and review it that way and
that's obviously not what happened
because and I don't like anything that I
do but even I after seeing the movie was
like this is a great great movie I
expected to get done that's what was
always happening and I figured was gonna
continue to happen but I was surprised
that the movie itself wasn't given more
respect but it has grown like year after
year after year it's growing this I
don't even know if it's can it even be
considered a cult following at this
point I feel like it's broken through
where it's just a lot of people are
obsessed with this movie they truly are
I hear more about this movie than any
other project I've worked on if I get
randomly stopped in the grocery store
it's which is strange enough for a
writer that doesn't happen to a lot of
screenwriters so I feel very fortunate
if somebody stops me it's always some
like 22 year old who wants to talk to me
about Jennifer's body and to me that is
the coolest thing in the world yeah
because it's like I don't even think you
could have legally seen this movie when
it came out and you found it they're
just boys morsels we have all the power
don't you know that these things these
are like smart bombs okay you point them
in the right direction and it's real can
you talk about because obviously I
wasn't in on like the audience testing
and the screens and and the testing for
the publicity in the marketing and all
about what was that like because
obviously something went in a very wrong
direction and where was that coming from
well the test screenings were were
horrible and I believe that's because of
the audience's that were recruited for
the screenings which we like frat boys
exactly the studio had a very strong
unshakable belief that this movie needed
to be marketed to young men specifically
so that was who you came because of me
I'm assuming yes yeah exactly
I got a very memorable email from from a
marketing person at the studio once
right I you know had sent him this
articulate defense of the film and here
is how it should be marketed and I said
what specifically are you thinking and
he wrote back Megan Fox hot three words
for so they're a trailer together that
was for marketing in terms of general in
terms of what is the value of this film
okay so that should give you an idea of
where okay where they were going with it
somebody was mentioning that at a test
screening or you had a test group and
somebody was like it needs more boobs I
still have the card so there was there
was a test screening that a kid wrote
they said what would you improve about
this film and the kid wrote and needs
more boobs and spelled boobs BEW BS and
that was the data that was collected and
taken seriously yeah by the people who
were marketing the movie so your
experience I feel like I am NOT a
performer and I feel like it must be a
tremendous amount of pressure to be sort
of centered on this poster or to be this
this the you're the face of the film and
people are savaging it yeah I mean not
to get too heavy but like you know is it
difficult for you or you just are you
thicker skin because of the profession
that you're in no I'm actually
incredibly sensitive and there was so
much going on with me at that time that
just the that movie being picked apart
wasn't at the top of my that I you know
I was getting bullied from all angles
and and it wasn't that that in
particular was was hurtful it was but it
there was so much happening between the
release of this movie
something very unfortunate was going on
for me publicity wise when this movie
when I was promoting this movie and then
some other things happened after that
and I was dealing with a tremendous
amount of negativity and I wasn't on
social media or anything like that but
it was just constantly and the tabloids
are on celebrity blogs like back when
Perez Hilton was like the website that
everybody went to do you remember when I
got photographed swimming in the lake
and I was horrified and I begged Dan do
Becky to call Perez Hilton and not post
those photos because I was just
destroyed over that I was so I was so
wrecked over that but but anyway it was
in that time before there was I was
getting any sort of social media
feedback which I'm not getting it now
anyway because I don't check it but it
was expected I guess I would say because
I had such a fraught relationship just
with the public and with the media and
with journalists and I was struggling so
much at that time in general that this
didn't stand out as like a particularly
painful moment it just was a part of the
mix but it was it's overwhelming because
what was happening there and you must
have been taking it back by like how
sexualized I was and how I was like
reduced to I mean objectified is like
it's not the right word it doesn't
capture what was happening to me at the
time yeah but it wasn't just what that
movie it was with every producer I
worked with so that was a Debray it
proceeded a breaking point for me where
you said you had to go into therapy I
had I think a genuine psychological
breakdown probably where I wanted just
nothing to do I didn't want to be seen
I didn't want to have to take a photo I
didn't want to have to do a magazine I
didn't want to have to walk carpet I
didn't want to have to be seen in public
at all because the fear and the the
belief the the absolute certainty that I
believed that I was going to be mocked
or spat at or someone would yell at me
or people would stone me or savage me
for just being out and being whatever I
didn't look perfect
I was too fat I was too thin I was
stupid I was offensive I was a waste of
space I was a bad actress whatever what
all of the all of the things you can
think of I I anticipated experiencing
that because my belief system was from
what I had experienced but the world
wasn't gonna accept me and so I had I
just went through a very dark moment
after that we must have been going
through it at the same time and yet I
don't know it wasn't because of this in
particular but this added to it of
course but just an I feel like you know
I was sort of out in front of the me to
movement before the need to movement
happened like yeah I was speaking out
and saying you know hey these things are
happening to me and they're not okay and
everyone was like yeah we don't care you
deserve it because you talk because of
how you look because value dress because
of the jokes you make that's why you
haven't really heard a lot from me on
that subject even though I have a lot to
say because to be honest I'm still
terrified people will say well she was a
stripper right we don't really care what
she like does she really have a right to
talk about being sexually objectified or
having been put through in Hollywood
because like she you know made that
choice for herself
yeah and it's her story is not valid so
it's I'm scared yeah I felt the same way
I felt like you know we live in this
moment right now where you you believe
victims but if there's ever gonna be one
person that it was okay not to believe
it would be me if it's ever gonna be
okay to shame a victim it's gonna be me
that is the belief because of what I've
been through and that's not to say that
it's right but it is a fear it's a the
same fear that that you're expressing
and not that I need to speak out so that
I can have some sort of healing but just
the fact that we struggle with that
privately is unfortunate because there's
still not really a space like I don't
feel like there's a space in feminism
for me
you know even though I consider myself a
feminist I feel like feminists don't
want me to be a part of their group and
what is what are we talking about then
what is feminism what is supporting
other females if there's only certain
ones of us you support if I have to be
an academic or I have to be not
threatening to you in some way why why
can't I be a part of the group as well
why do I have to be dismissed
because of what annalen and now
especially what did I ever really do
that was so provocative or so bad
nothing it's applying to me considering
all the stuff that's happened since then
and what's happening on a regular basis
in this country and with celebrities
that we have everyday I never really did
anything that crazy but I was really
drug through the coals for a lot of it
I'm very permeable and I'm very
sensitive and so I don't show that um
I'm not stoic that's not the right word
people think I'm standoffish but it's
usually because I have to be I'm trying
to put up a wall so I don't absorb
everything you are feeling and he's
feeling and this person is feeling and
take it with me and that energy was sort
of penetrating me at that time in my
life and I definitely brought that to
set and offset and just in general I was
living that for a minute and that made
me wonder if you had somebody specific
we were inspired by what I was really
basing it on was myself because I was
going through this transition in my own
life where what I really AM in real life
if we're gonna use Jennifer's body
characters as a metaphor I'm a needy
okay like I'm a I am a bookish insecure
cowardly person and I had created and my
real name is Brooke and I had created
this Diablo Cody persona to serve to
survive and to get attention which is
something that I desperately needed at
that time in my life because nobody ever
listened to me and then suddenly when I
changed my name and started doing
uncharacteristic things suddenly for the
very first time in my life people were
interested you know I've never
experienced Fame on your level nothing
even remotely close but I was suddenly
like a public figure which is unusual
for a writer and I was like chasing the
dragon in a way like will you get used
to that level of attention and you want
more of it even though you know it's
toxic and you know it's not really who
you are mm-hmm and luckily like right
after the movie came out and flopped I
was able to like pull the ripcord and I
got pregnant like
it was not a coincidence that the movie
came out and I got pregnant like a month
later because I was like I'm done like I
don't like I need a different identity
now this one is this was this is bad
news like I'm gonna be a mom I'm gonna
be Brooke and I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
I'm not gonna go to red carpets and I'm
not gonna go to events and I like I just
didn't want to be any type of public
figure anymore so I just made that
decision which I don't regret like I've
gotten better every day since then yeah
but it yeah was like it was definitely
like a sort of autobiographical for me
writing that movie and no one has ever
actually asked me that so it's it feels
cathartic to talk about was Jennifer
than the projection of your your alter
ego then yeah and Jennifer were Brooke
and yeah exactly yeah because media is
the person who's looking around going
this is all really messed up like this
is like this isn't okay and Jennifer's
flicking the lighter on her tongue which
I love that that's become a very popular
iconic gif yeah but I get sent all the
time yeah but like who knew so one thing
that that people have asked me about
recently is me too and the way that this
like perhaps this film is finding more
of a sympathetic audience now because it
is dealing with themes of like consent
assault like mail mail abuse of power
what I had specifically and talking
about all of this more recently was I
realized that in filming that scene
where they sacrificed me that for me
that was really reflective of I felt
like my relationship with the movie
studios at that point because I felt
like that's what they were willing to do
to literally bleed me dry they didn't
care about my health my well-being
mentally emotionally physically at all
and they were willing to sacrifice me
physically as long as they got what they
wanted out of it and it didn't matter
how many times I spoke up and said I'm
hurting this isn't right I need someone
to protect me this is going on someone
needs to listen it didn't matter at all
and so in that moment they kind of were
a representation of what I was dealing
with that way but a lot of people love
that band that fictional band they who
created that's become iconic on its own
which is really interest
and I see people I see people dressed as
Jennifer for Halloween I see people
dressed as Adams character everything
that I do you were such a player-hater
jerk Wow nice insult Hannah Montana
though my six-year-old he's almost 7 he
was was easy I use six last year he was
a zombie cheerleader he hasn't seen the
movie my son super creative and so like
he likes to design clothes and sometimes
he wears dresses and he's he's super
he's like a little fashion designer or I
love paint like a mad painter he's like
a van Gogh he's like a crazy maniac for
art but he wanted to I don't know why he
wanted to be a zombie cheerleader that's
just he came up with that on his own and
when he chose that I said you know I
kind of played a character like that in
a movie before they don't really they
still don't really understand what that
means that I'm in a movie but it isn't
real yeah because they think that
whatever is happening I actually
experienced and I made the mistake and I
don't know why I did this he wanted to
see how she becomes a zombie so I show
him the scene in the woods where they're
gonna sacrifice me he's so sensitive I
don't know why I did that he was
hysterical and he talks about it still
it's been almost a year because he
doesn't understand and I kept I was like
look at me I'm right here I'm laughing
it's okay that's not Mariana I was
pretending the way you fake cry when you
want something I was faking it's not but
I think he it's it's too much eh for any
child to see but also I think he was
because that scene was intense for me
and I forgot where I went with it and
he's the the crying and the pain like
was genuine in that moment I think he
feels that obviously they're connected
to us you understand yeah they're
connected to our energy and so he was he
he had a hard time with that but I know
that when he's a little bit older he's
gonna be he's gonna be a big Jennifer
his body fan and I expect to see him as
jennifer check for Halloween at some
point in the near future
I mean that's the coolest thing ever it
is really cool and you know when you're
making I don't know what you were
thinking when you were making the movie
I never make a movie and
this is gonna be iconic like I've never
known ever what I'm on set making a
movie so it's funny when that happens in
in retrospect it ends up happening now
ten years later I look up and I'm like
God that was a really fun character that
was a really special movie it's funny
that you say that you know you don't
expect things to become iconic I was
specifically pessimistic because I cared
so much about the movie and because it
was so personal so specific and so weird
I knew the movie was not going to be
successful and I feel terrible saying
that but I just thought to myself like I
did not write this to conform to any
model of films that succeed moveon.org
Edie it's over life is too short to be
moping around
that's sweet Jen do you think though
looking back that just for you
personally maybe that was a blessing
because had you continued on that same
trajectory of being in a vicious cycle
with attention and with fame had that
movie been very successful it would have
propelled you even further into the
ether and you may have floated away and
never come back
and maybe I would never have been a
mother or not the kind of mother that
you are now I yes yes it is a blessing
and it was and it was also a
character-building experience that made
me a better writer because I think of
everything you do is successful in
general you become complacent and you
start to believe your own hype and like
yeah for me it was especially at that
time in my life I needed to have the
bubble burst yeah so yeah it was
actually it worked out I just hope I
would just I wish it hadn't cost people
but you know but what did it cost them
really because yes it costs you mean
people lost money investing in the movie
and yeah they lost opportunities like
you know I mean yeah you think about
that it's when you that's the thing
about writing a of movies or a TV series
is you feel like the godmother of the
project in a way and you feel like there
are sort of hundreds of people depending
on you for it to succeed and I try to
put that out of my mind because it's
crippling it
it is a thought you have you're like a
lot of lives are riding on this idea
yeah but it's also a matter of
perspective like when somebody feels
like they've lost something in terms of
that experience because I I drink tea
every morning and sometimes my tea has
little special sayings and mantras on it
and one of them that I like is the only
difference between a flower and a weed
is a judgment and that's the truth
sometimes we look at things because we
have a specific map of how we're going
to get to this goal and what our future
is supposed to look like and when
something doesn't happen we consider it
a failure or we consider that we've lost
something and that we're suffering and
that the universe is against us but the
opposite is true the universe is always
conspiring on our behalf to weave
everything together for good but you
just have to shift your perspective so
at that time I felt like I was suffering
but now having a different outlook
having grown the way that I've grown it
made me a much better human being we
were sort of in a parallel in some way
even when we seemed so different I was
feeling and going through a lot of the
same things you were feeling and going
through and when you say like you were
living a character that wasn't you and
you were addicted to the character but
you also didn't know how to get out of
the character even though it was toxic
and painful that was absolutely when I
was living at the time and I think it
took and you are being made to play that
character which i think is even more
traumatic
shoehorned into by was pushed into it
then I can't totally play a victim
because I took over and I was like if
this is what it is it's what it is I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it full force
but it was not genuine and that's never
you're never gonna thrive when you're
being disingenuous to yourself and I
think it took getting pregnant that was
the first real breakthrough where I had
where I might my consciousness shifted
and my mind opened up and I was able to
see from our bird's eye view and breathe
and take it in and and have a different
perspective and then another kid and
then another kid in with every kid I
feel like that's always been the doorway
into a better version of myself because
they're you know they're the mirrors
that show you your shadow you have to
look at it and go this is Who I am and I
have to acknowledge that and I have to
grow when I have to
you need a mani badge you should find a
Chinese chick to buff your situation
also I don't know if you get this I get
this all the time people will be like
you just don't really work that much
like journalist will be like what do you
I mean it's nice to see you in a movie
because you don't really work that much
and it's like I have given birth I've
just stated and given birth to three
children I starred in a movie that
opened worldwide number one twice I was
on a critically acclaimed sitcom I
executive produced and created a show
about archaeological controversies how
much more does a woman need to be Yahoo
and I'm in an industry that treats
pregnancy like leprosy so it's not like
I can keep working once I'm past five
months I just do nothing it is what it
is and that's so frustrating for me
because it's like when you are when
you're in Oscar realm or when you're in
this like huge blockbuster place and
you're a pinup or whatever you want to
call me it's like everything you do
after that needs to be on the side
because you've had a Morgan of ubiquity
or you're failing yes
and that doesn't it doesn't work that
way how about cut us a break especially
as women who are doing who are creating
life as well as working you can't expect
me to be putting out the same kind of
things at the same kind of pace which I
was never really an ambitious yeah
worker but as when I was a kid and had
no children and wasn't married and had a
different life so for me that's really
annoying and very frustrating because
it's like how can you you start off here
yeah which we both did yeah and so then
if you if you're nuts next project is
here which is still miles above where
most people ever make it yeah yeah well
I knew I was I was from the beginning
because I want an Oscar for my first
screenplay yeah so everybody says so how
many are you gonna win I was like one
like this is it you really think I'm
gonna win another oscar like that
doesn't happen to people
thrilled to have one I looked at it
every day but I am NOT in a never been
in a place where I think to myself like
okay I need to I need to sustain that
level of success because how could you
yeah and also like I had three kids yeah
and it's a miracle that I'm here like
being able to sit here and discuss this
with you is a
and achievement for me because I got
three kids you know out of the house
this morning and I'm tired any people
don't it's in my experience at least
being a mother is not something that's
really respected in this industry if
anything it's considered like kind of a
not at least your the handicap it is
having to leave to go work all the time
which I'm sure you do also is really
it's hard when you have little kids even
if you're staying in town but you're
going to work or what I do traveling far
away your mind is always somewhere else
as well because your heart is always
somewhere else you're always worried
about what's going on with them and the
guilt of having left them and are you
doing the right thing and then
struggling with well what do I need to
do for me for my creativity and Who am I
outside of just being a mother because
that's not my only identity yeah it's
very complicated and people don't give
enough credit to people who are dealing
with that because it's not it's not easy
it weighs on you the constant like every
room I walk into I look for everything
that could possibly go wrong if there's
an earthquake what's gonna fall off of
the wall if we're in a movie theater how
are we gonna get out of here
active-shooter about the but I do too
but it's constant and it's so draining
and nobody talks about that the the
preoccupation with the child's safety
and just just get through this day and
don't choke on a piece of food please
like this just that just don't choke
that don't struggle for me to worry
about all three kids nobody talks about
it ya know if they don't and it it is it
really is draining after I had one of my
son's I had to go do reshoots they they
scald me I gave birth they called me to
do reshoots two weeks afterwards they're
like is she ready to do reshoots and I
was like no a person just came out of my
vagina I'm not ready to go do reshoots
what are you talking about so they they
were graceful and gracious and they gave
me like I think I went back four or five
weeks later I think it was four weeks
later and trying to negotiate being
allowed to go to my trailer to
breastfeed my baby was almost impossible
because they don't because you know you
have to breastfeed every two and a half
or three hours depending on what
schedule your breastfeed yeah almost
impossible because they don't understand
you know what it is onset if you if you
take two minutes away it's like
everybody's super stressed out about
every moment that goes
why because the time is money yeah and
so it's my point is it's a hostile
environment for you for new mothers or
any mothers in general a lot of people
have stopped me in begged for this movie
to be turned into a series or a show or
to be reborn somehow yeah so I'm
assuming you've been asked the same
thing and what do you think about that
so here's what's interesting like maybe
five years ago I really wanted to try
and do
Jennifer's body as a TV series and there
was so little interest that I couldn't
even get to the pitch stage like people
didn't even want to hear the pitch and
the argument that I kept making as I
said because they said why would we want
why would anyone make a television show
about a movie that did not succeed and I
said have you heard of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer that movie was not well-received
and then went on to become this
incredibly inspired series that was a
huge hit so I said this would be the
exact same thing like like like at least
hear the pitch and nobody would so and
then now all of a sudden I'm getting
calls about it people are very
interested in doing something like that
they're just jealous cause you're not
invited jealous disgusting everyone in
there has a mustache
you're totally jealous you're lime-green
jello and you can't even admit it to
yourself would there be any fear of not
doing justice to the original yeah there
would be some fear there and at the same
time I do think that I I feel so
connected unlike oh just a really deep
primal level to this project I think I
think I know what's right for this baby
and I don't think I would screw it up
I get asked about it all the time I mean
I died in the movie so I don't know but
it's magical
you could be bathroom I would be back I
mean I loved it it's my favorite thing
I've ever done I did not know that and
I'm happy to hear really yeah what would
you think my favorite thing would be
that I've done she needs me and under
terms perhaps Jonah Hex I don't know you
want to talk about a movie if whenever
you're feeling bad about yourself go
read some Jonah Hex reviews that'll make
you feel better you should be happy for
me because
I'm having the best days than like Jesus
invented the calendar Jesus didn't
invent the calendar whatever I get
people coming up and quoting at me all
the time you know what see so this
doesn't really happen to me because you
know I'm a little underground as a
writer I was what do people say to you
it smells like Thai food in here it
smells like Thai food in here have you
guys been that's my favorite quality
yeah okay I'm thrilled to hear that
people are quoting that's one of the
ones that I think has lived forever I
hear that one the most I don't think I
have a favorite quote I mean that line
was really fun to deliver and deliver it
you did you delivered like Domino's baby
that was I love it there are a lot of
really fun things to say you don't have
a favorite thing that you wrote in the
in the script you know I I don't know if
this is appreciated
but I love because it speaks to what
you've been talking about here in terms
of how women are objectified when when
jennifer has been stabbed and says my
tit and lady says no your heart to me
it's like the audience is looking at her
chest and seeing at it and what I'm
trying to show them is her heart media
and chip had some great moments - OH
classic chips asking her if he's too big
she's like having this demonic like this
moment where she's seeing a horrible
vision as she starts screaming during
sex and Johnny Simmons says am I too big
Johnny Simmons was brilliant when I
first saw it I was so thrilled
I left the edit I was overwhelmed I was
in tears and Mason our producer was with
me and we were both so happy so then
when the movie was screened we were
knocked for a loop because we but what
happened at the screening people are
like oh my god people eviscerated did
they not understand that it was a comedy
they were they disappointed it wasn't a
straight horror movie what what were
they up what were they obsessive so they
had recruited two types of people for
the screening is I'm gathering based on
the data we received people who were
huge fans of Juno which is not the same
kind of movie and and many of whom were
horrified and said like I want I came
here to see a cute movie like Juno and
there's murder in this you know it was
like a they were not even prepared to
see a horror film and then the other
part of the audience was guys who wanted
to see something very specific from you
what aid and group or the guys I mean if
I had to guess I would say they were 18
to 24 okay coveted precious white male
18 to 24 demographic was there I do not
recall seeing a lot of girls there at
all you know what's funny is people
assume like they assumed that most of my
fanbase is male and it's not true it's
young girls oh I know that from looking
at an Instagram and Twitter and the post
that I get sent yeah that it is women
its teenage early 20s like you said yeah
females hmm so obviously the studio
misread that as well and thought those
people but also why give those people
any sort of creative input into how a
movie should be made or not made at all
why do they do that at all why do they
do those test screenings and ask who
gives what 19 year old douche thinks do
you buy all your murder weapons at Home
Depot gosh watch I got a call from my
agent saying there's an opportunity for
you to work on this movie that was
written by Diablo Cody she wrote you
know was I at that premiere you were and
I have a photo of the two of us together
and you do look like you were dragged I
thought the army right I remember I was
wearing a Motley Crue t-shirt I thought
I was super cool at the time I mean it
was cool I was going through like I'm
gonna be like grungy and rock and I just
don't have any of that in me at all it's
totally fake
but so I went to that I don't know if I
was signed on to do it yet it was like
in the process I think I don't remember
like about to yes and I'll be recording
you I'm I'm not yeah so we had to take a
picture together on the red carpet
what's the point of that why do they
make us do that why does it matter why
would I sign on to a movie just because
we walked a red carpet together or
vice-versa I want to be in your movie
because I came to the premiere do you
know one has nothing to do with each
other it's don't antiquated they just
love that stuff they stay like that yeah
doesn't mean anything I think I read it
I don't even think I read it all the way
through I think I
like 30 pages in and was like I really
want to do this movie because it was so
I don't feel like anybody else could
have done it but me and that's such a
very that's such a I'm not trying to no
I've said this many times you heard I
was in that space I kind of was that
person in a way it was like the allegory
of what was going on in my life and so
it was the perfect project for me at
that moment and so I never I never
questioned it
[Music]
[Applause]